je pensais à vous cette nuit je me suis
arrivé à lui disais les noms de familles
veulent dire quelque chose quand même
non non c'est vrai moi moi rana un ébat
et ça veut dire crottes de nez et c'est
vrai que
c'est vrai que voilà dans la famille on
a de très belles randonnées donc avant
la vie c'était nos ancêtres il sortait
les chronos hanouna hanouna et je me
disais tu vois castaldi ça veut dire
quoi je vais vous dire pourquoi castaldi
je sais pourquoi j'ai trouvé je vous
jure que c'est vrai et ses ancêtres il
devait avoir lancé cette relance est
l'ancêtre de son père il devait par
l'ozone
exact a dit
[Applaudissements]
de leur mot jazz et d'ailleurs mots de
quoi déborder mon or avant et voilà qui
parle bien d qui supprime garder nos
jours moi je pense en bas tu penses à
côté et puis toi le bigorneau un truc
mais à manier pourquoi m'a dit ça des
procureurs
en faire du judo sera
[Rires]
vraiment quelque chose vous avouera
écoute et hop oui c'est quoi va arriver
au caire les bourgs effet des bourgs et
on perd parce que je te vire je me suis
pas fait tout seul je ne suis pas à pas
qui
c'est quoi donc le crochet les crochets
manche et alors c'est bien de là à bout
bah pourquoi vous fatiguent il été
primés
verdez voit les gens savaient pourquoi
vous appelez bernès mais en retour parce
que vos ancêtres à l'époque 1 quand il
est allé chez vous dans cette île disait
on va pernez vers le nerf
disons à vous connaître
vous avez jalousie d'être à l'aise et
vert ds mon avis mme wade à nîmes mais
dany massé c'est parce qu'elle est dans
la torah
pierrette harold bennett a cole
est l'école benhaim est certaine
manière si bnm t'offre une paire de
chaussettes c'est parce que tu as froid
aux pieds
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et haï matole tibre à thoiras est allé
tu veux dire s'il pleut mais naim te
demande de prendre un parapluie
guillaume genton avec l'entourage antho
genton je crois
j'entends le loup le renard
shalalala c'est une chance
genton regarder le direct et harris mal
au départ c'est guillaume menton
je vous aime un très bon menton versées
et donc ses ancêtres aussi j'étais tout
petit mais voilà ma façon de chanter
montons les gens qui avaient un bon
menton exactement je vous le dis les
vétos fait du bien j'ai un taux castaldi
pédo vdo oui bah c'est beau et jacob non
pas très beau quand mr exhalant qui
complique la vie dont velits oui abaca
avait dominé le vélo on cherche
vdo vélib séance est votée dès jeanne
hidalgo
la plupart travaillent tous à tout faire
un sort aux morts
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour entraîneur isabelle moret
ce sont deux entités sur la forme
des gens qui demandait qu'une chose
s'était passé l'armé à gauche
mais perd tout aux
mères pères ni comment s'habiller et
tu perds partout tu seras de nikos un
accord ou des voix la mort et du beau
j'aurais plutôt dit les champignons du
bois les morilles
ouais mais non les champignons
[Applaudissements]
je me suis pris la tête toute la nuit
parfaite vous êtes mannequin chanteur
généalogistes voilà bientôt je vais être
quelqu'un qui va faire du ménage